complete the statement using less than
or greater than that's what those
symbols are for this kind of brackets
there so all they're asking is they have
a 5 and they have a 2 and they want us
to put either a less than sign for these
brackets or a greater than sign so if we
just have a five and a two and we're
just comparing the two which number is
greater well five is greater if you
count to five you're going to pass up
two if you look at a number line here if
you started at 0 1 2
3
4
5. you see that 2 comes before 5 2 is
less than 5. if i have 2 dollars that's
less than 5 dollars so or 5 is greater
than 2. and so the symbol for greater
than the way you remember this is
probably the hardest part of how do you
remember it is you want the larger side
of the symbol facing the larger number
so 5 is a larger number so we want the
bigger side of the symbol so we want it
like this the way i think about it is
that this right here is the big side of
the symbol
and this right here this point is a
small side of the symbol so 5 is greater
than 2. if it was the other way we would
write 2 is less than 5 once again though
we always have the point pointing to the
smaller to the smaller number and we
have the wide open part the big part of
the symbol pointing to the larger number